all right so um
with openings i can't play everything so
i want i would like to play a sicilian
in this game
and we face a c3 sicilian uh generally
i'm on the white side of this opening
but here we're on the black side and as
you guys know i've said this many many
times black has two main moves d5 and
knight f6 both of which immediately
contest the center
in this particular game i would like to
play knight f6 because this is actually
what i play irl this is my main move
and um
if you are familiar with the
alakine uh this is a similar it's like
you're playing the alakan with the
inclusion of the move c5 and c3 which
clearly favor black because
the pawn on c5 controls the center of
the pawn on c3 deprives the knight of
that square and just like in the alicon
you go knight t5 so this is
very
standard theory and generally white goes
either d4 and f3
okay so
first things first we should take this
pawn because if we don't take it
white will take our pawn and there's no
need to give white that opportunity so
we take the pawn
and uh actually it turns out white
doesn't have to take back immediately if
he doesn't want to because the knight on
d5 was x-rayed by the queen
how to approach uh this position black
has many viable setups here
uh there are setups connected with the
move e6 you can play knight c6
but i think that the the most
straightforward way of continuing here
is to basically say all right well
white's got this pretty pretty
impressive pawn center
we want to kind of cut into it we don't
want to let white solidify
you know that pawn center
which would potentially make our
position kind of cramped right
so what does it mean to like
counter our opponent's center well we
want to try to break up this pawn chain
ideally we would hit the pawn on d4 but
we can't do that we already traded our
pawn on c7 so the next best thing is to
play d6 and
you know if white takes it then we take
with the queen and we've got a great
blockade on d5 that is why the c3
sicilian often leads to isolated queen
pawn or iqp positions because if this
trade occurs
which it just did
this is a classic iqp position
i've talked about it many many times
and if we're facing an iqp
the most important thing generally
speaking is to have the square in front
of it controlled preferably by a knight
which is exactly what we have here which
is why taking on d6 is not it's not a
big mistake but it's not the most
testing option
okay so how should we continue well here
we we should complete our development as
efficiently as possible
so let's begin by developing our knight
to c6
obviously
um
we need to develop this bishop and the
other bishop and based on how white
plays we'll figure out where to put
those pieces
why d6 and not f6 well because f6 is
very weakening generally
playing the move f6 as ben feingold will
tell you is
very committal that weakens this
diagonal
there's no need to do that when we can
do it in the center
never play f6 particularly not that
early in the game
um all right
so generally white plays knight c3 here
or he can develop this bishop yeah
knight c3
okay um
so we need to figure out what our
development scheme is going to be here
uh
and
in order to do that we have to determine
which bishop we're going to develop
first are we going to work on this
bishop first by playing g6 or e6 or are
we going to develop the light squared
bishop first well the movie 6 is very
solid here because it supports the
knight
it prepares to get the bishop out to e7
pretty decent move absolutely
the drawback of the movie 6 is as you
can see that the bishop on c8 is blocked
in by the pawn although you could argue
that later on you could fianchetto that
bishop as well maybe
maybe maybe you can
um
but i could see a stronger case being
made as we often like to do for
developing this bishop
outside of the pawn chain first and then
playing e6 so that the bishop is
free to roam and free to control the
center of the board
where to put this bishop well we can put
it on g4 and pin the knight
pretty pretty decent move or we can put
it on f5 which is a pretty nice square
for the bishop in these types of
positions
i think you guys probably lean toward
pinning the knight
which contains some interesting
complications but
i'm going to do that let's spin the
knight
how do you determine and a lot of people
have this question like how do i know
whether to play e6 or g6
well i don't and the move g6 is a pretty
decent one in this position
i'm going to write this down and after
the game i will explain in greater
detail why
um
why i don't want to play g6 specifically
here there are a couple of reasons
that i that i don't like g6 as much
but generally there's no formula for
deciding whether to put the bishop on e7
or to fianchetto with it all depends on
the position
but here we're gonna go e6 partially i
like that this solidifies the knight
even further
uh and and g6 there's a sense in which
it's it's a little bit slow although
both of these take two moves to develop
the bishop
okay h3
now should we take the knight here
what do you guys think should we take
the night here
no that's a bad trade it brings white's
bishop to a more active spot
that's pretty basic stuff we should just
drop it back there's no need
no need to trade
unless you you are specifically winning
the d4 pawn
trading in this type of position is not
advisable and even if you are
giving up such a bishop can backfire
pretty spectacularly
okay so he's probably going to castle
we're going to go bishop e7
um and then we are going to castle at
first opportunity
so essentially we've completed our
development we have a great position
blockading knight on t5
and our plan
is going to be to start pressuring this
isolated queen pond that is white's only
big weakness and
we've got it blockaded so we're going to
have to mount some sustained pressure on
that pawn trying to win it eventually
wow zarcon that's awesome congrats
okay rookie one
that doesn't change anything so
it's time for us to castle
well castle and queen side is not a good
idea here largely because the c file is
semi-open and it's going to be occupied
by white's rook and that gives white
essentially a ready-made attack
okay
so one of the positives for playing
against an isolated queen pawn is if you
have it blockaded the moves are quite
automatic
like in order to improve black's
position you've got several moves which
just kind of play themselves one of them
is to bring the rook into d8 building
more pressure on the pawn and
reinforcing the knight
someone suggested the idea of rerouting
the bishop to c7
in order to build
a potential battery that's a pretty
creative idea
but
one of the good ways that you can test
whether an idea is good or not is
imagine that your opponent lets you play
all of the moves you want to play
then you look at the final position and
you basically say well in that resulting
position
will my opponent have some way to take
this thing out of my idea so let's apply
that to
the plan just proposed let's imagine
that our bishop moves from e7 to c7 here
and it's white to play
does white have anything unpleasant in
that resulting position
i think a lot of you guys are seeing it
there's the move knight b5 which trades
off the bishop
defeating the entire purpose of getting
it there in the first place so you might
say well then let's play a6 first and
then get our bishop to c7 that's already
three moves and that's a pretty long
time
and i've talked about the three move
rule which is a good
way to estimate whether your ideas take
too long or not i think if an idea takes
three moves or longer and the position
is pretty open
generally it's going to be on the
unrealistic side
okay bishop g5
so
that's what i would call a positional
mistake
what is a positional mistake positional
mistake is a move that's not a blunder
but although this one borders on being a
blunder i don't think it is though
um but it it is strategically wrong like
it helps us accomplish our plan
or it you know
it is to the detriment of
you know the positioning of the pieces
um
as i've talked about before in an iqp
structure
who benefits from
the who benefits from minor piece trades
is it the side with the iqp or the side
playing against it and why
you don't have to type out your answer
just um think about that for a second
yeah so we benefit from it the side
playing against the iqp generally
benefits
from minor b straights
um
why is that well the simple explanation
is that the more pieces disappear off
the board the harder it's going to be to
defend the pawn on d4 white's going to
have to allocate like imagine if i just
has a queen and a rook
well then both of those pieces are going
to have to
be tied down to the defense of the iqp
and white's not going to have any pieces
left over for any kind of active
operations there is a very famous karpov
courtship game where that happened i've
shown it before on stream
now that doesn't always happen that
doesn't mean you never want to trade if
you have the iqp but that's what's going
to happen here i think
so as black we want to trade off
as many lights as many minor pieces is
possible we can do that in two different
ways a lot of you are seeing that we can
take the knight first that seems to win
a piece but it doesn't
um because white takes the bishop on e7
first
we have to recapture and then the bishop
takes f3 i don't want to leave white
with an uncontested light squared bishop
on f3 so
i would like to take this first
and then once the knight takes i would
like to trade the bishops as well
leaving us with just four nights on the
board
now you might be like well
are iqp's ever good
well they are um
and if you have an iqp the most skilled
players
know how to handle it in a way to
produce attacking chances there are some
brilliant attacking games where the side
of the iqp either pushes it with a
breakthrough or creates kingside chances
so it's not good or bad it's it's just a
complicated structure
isolated queen pod
but if you don't know you could google
it i'm pretty sure it'll pop up
why not keep the light squared bishop as
i just explained
it's all about
sort of long-term strategy we're trying
to trade off pieces all right
so
this is a good time to
refresh the idea of one move threat itis
i can guarantee that a lot of you are
thinking about going h6 here at least
you want to play h6
or you want to play queen
f4 queen f4 is a better move than h6 but
i don't like either of them
well it is a double attack so queen f4
is a double attack on the knight of the
pawn
but you're kind of taking your eyes off
the football a little bit you're taking
your eyes off of the d59 no i like the
move queen f4
it just has to be calculated um
so after queen f4 white can play knight
takes d5
and then in that position which of the
knights do we actually want to take
after queen f4 knight takes d5 do we
want to take the d5 pawn knight with the
pawn or the or the g5 knight with the
queen
we definitely want to take the g5 knight
with the queen because if we take the d5
knight with a pawn the pawn structure
becomes symmetrical white's knight can
drop back to f3 and we will be unable to
win the d4 pawn the position becomes
equal
it's only by taking on g5 that we
preserved the iqp for white
all right
um so that's one option what are the
other options here
i think we've got one other really good
option which is just to make a very
simple improving move you don't really
need to do anything here
all that you want to do here is improve
your position
and increase the pressure on the pawn
i've already mentioned this move what am
i talking about
just rook a to d8
why there because that rook and the
queen are going to be stacked up and
once the knight moves away from d5 the
pressure on d4 might get unbearable
now you might be thinking well isn't it
a problem that we're leaving the knight
on g5 well that knight in and of itself
is not dangerous
even if white brings the queen up to d3
you might be scared of the mate threat
but that's not a scary threat you can
just play pawn to g6 and white lacks the
minor pieces to really exploit the
weakness of the squares
um why not the f rook to d8 well i
wouldn't play rook fd8 because it would
leave the king a little bit too
undefended it would leave no pieces
surrounding the king but didn't you just
say that the king is not in any danger
well yes but partially that's because we
would leave one rook to supervise the f7
pawn make sure there are no shenanigans
with knight takes f7
work fd8 is not terrible but i wouldn't
feel safe leaving my king like this
um
why would you play knight f6 i feel like
it's too early to release the blockade
on the pawn
but what i would worry about in the
event of knight f6 is white actually
pushing that d-pawn
in a particular situation i don't want
to allow that option
so let's get rick ada queen f4 would
have also been great
but i want to show you guys the power of
just keeping the tension and making
these simple moves
and knight f4 is similarly
um hasty because white can play rook d2
and they're kind of helping white pile
on the defenders on the pawn
and that knight on f4 is going to be a
loose loose cannon it might get attacked
and
it's not all about making moves that
look aggressive
yeah but i'm blocking the iqp that's a
good thing that's called a blockade
we're only going to unblockade the pawn
when we're ready to capture it that's
the point of a blockade
okay so he goes queen d3
and we will now go pawn to g6 blunting
the queen
now under which circumstances would a
move like g6 be bad well if for example
white still had a dark squirt bishop
weakening these squares would be very
dangerous it could potentially lead to a
lobster pincer mate i wouldn't want to
do that
here yeah maybe a knight could land on
f6 but we've got enough pieces nearby to
make sure those are defended
notice how it's all very relative to the
pieces that remain on the board whether
something is a serious weakness or not
depends entirely on
what's left on the board like can your
opponent exploit it
so make sure you're not thinking too
generally about like weak squares knight
f4 is also a big threat here
as you guys are indicating
okay
so hopefully everything makes sense so
far
yeah so weakness is one if it can be
exploited that's absolutely correct
i believe the black is slightly better
here not much better but slightly better
for sure
why play g6 because white was
threatening checkmate in one move
two attackers on h7
all right so we're waiting on
our opponent to make a move here
the iqp is definitely becoming more of a
weakness than a strength
all right
yeah he's playing very well so far
knight takes d5
okay obviously queen takes d5 that's the
whole point of what we've just done
which is to keep the d file open gila
gifting to tommy
knight back to f3 well
our strategy has triumphed we are now
ready to take the pawn one two three
attackers and only one two defenders it
all checks out we can take the pawn
uh the thing to understand is also that
um
like when you have an iqp we won upon is
the game over like obviously it's not
over
the game has just begun in many ways
we're still gonna have to win
potentially an endgame up upon but
at this level
you know things do not come easy you're
not just going to win every game with
checkmate
that's what a positional game is is you
got to win it gradually so
we'll see if white trades queens or not
in either case white is down upon
now we need to transition to the second
stage which is the technical phase of
the game
where we try to convert our advantage
queen b3 good move
refusing the trade
okay so
the pawn is currently attacked we've got
a million ways to defend the important
thing about these positions is that
you don't want to get too bogged down
trying to be ultra precise
generally there's going to be two or
three good moves thank you for the one
dollar
um
in each position so you shouldn't waste
five minutes deciding between b6 and
rook d7 i like rook d7 because it
prepares
uh tripling rooks
in such positions you also kind of want
to kill two birds with one stone like if
you're defending the pawn you might as
well prepare
prepare
another improvement of another piece so
rook fd8 is coming we're going to be
tripled on the d file always good to be
tripled on an open file
yeah queen d5 was also fine again
if you're asking a question of the form
why not this move chances are in this
position
that move is also fine even b6 is
totally normal you can play b6 here
queen d5 is great as well
even queen d3 was a nice move which i
missed um that could have forced a queen
trade but not not saying that black
necessarily wants a queen trade here
we're happy to keep the queens on the
board for now
we're happy to keep the queens on the
board our queen is great
and when the time comes we can play
queen d3 and trade if we want to
so understand that
you know
whether or not there are alternatives
depends on the position
in some positions there are in some
positions you kind of have to be
accurate rook c2 great move he's playing
very very well
not making it easy on us
all right so
[Music]
what does white want here um
it's hard to say i mean rook c8 might be
a little bit annoying
in fact rook c8 is quite annoying
rook c7 is also
is perhaps even even more annoying than
rooksyadas because that
that could create um
some issues with our pawns and i see a
nice indirect defense against rook c7
so i'm gonna play the move and i'm gonna
explain it afterward i'm gonna go king
g7 this is a multi-purpose move that
defends against both rook c768 why does
it defend against rook c8 it doesn't
physically defend against it but it
takes the sting out of rooks c8 because
we'll be able to take that rook thank
you lefong for the raid with the party
of 141 will be able to take that rook
and when white recaptures it's not going
to be check any longer what does that
mean well that means we have a move and
we can use that move to trade queens on
d1 if you calculate the line
welcome everybody we're doing a speedrun
game
thank you lafon
but what about rook c7 what have i
intended here well against rook c7
that's a little bit more complicated to
explain this is a more tactical idea he
doesn't play it i'll explain it after
the game
queen f3
okay
well um
again a couple of things that we can do
but um i really like the idea of moving
the queen away from d4 in order to give
the rooks greater control
over the d-file that queen is kind of in
the way
where would we bring the queen to well i
like the idea of going queen f6 because
that seems to be a nice follow-up to the
previous move king g7 right
the queen is very nicely out of the way
here but it's not out of the game it's
it's looking at that b2 pawn it's doing
stuff
and if white doesn't trade queens we're
just gonna slowly improve our position
until we see a chance to make further
progress
there's no
algorithm for winning these positions
you got to be super patient you got to
make small improvements
eventually a chance will present itself
if you're playing a human being
which hopefully you are okay
so already here we have an opportunity
which we could exploit or not
it's not clear whether it's a good idea
or not but you should at least notice
that it exists what am i talking about
yeah
so we can give a check on d1 and trade a
pair of rooks
i don't particularly like that idea why
not well let's calculate rook t1 rook
takes d1 rook takes d1 king h2
what happens in that resulting position
well if you look very carefully
you'll see two things first of all a7 is
hanging right
second of all we have left the seventh
rank which means that white stroke on c2
which has not been traded could
potentially emerge on c7
starting to create threats against our
queen side pawns and maybe even against
our king
so i don't see the rush in going rook t
when i feel like that's not a move white
is going to be able to prevent in the
long term
i much prefer making the comm move b6
let's defend the pawn
uh let's create a little pawn chain and
maybe later we'll play rook t1
a6 was also good a6 or b6 i think are
probably equivalent maybe even a6 is
stronger than b6
but it really doesn't matter
okay
we're slowly bleeding white's clock he's
gonna have to work a lot harder than we
will
keeping tabs on everything
now you might be looking at this and
saying well this is a pretty boring game
but hopefully if you're listening to me
talk about the logic you'll actually see
that a lot goes into these simple
looking moves
and
if you engage with the position you will
also find these positions more
interesting than they seem
now i am intending a move which you'll
see a lot of gm's play this is like a
classic move a lot of people look at it
and say
i don't understand this move i'm not
never going to be able to play such a
move but it's a very nice way to improve
our position and that's the move h5
and what's the point of it it's not to
create luft right because our kings are
the back rank is not an issue
the point is to advance the spawn all
the way to h4
and clamp down as much as possible on
white's king's side pawns this is really
good in an end game where pawn mobility
is important and this is even good
uh with all of the pieces on the board
because in some alternate universe
you might envision a situation where
white's king is on h2
and we essentially take away its escape
square on g3 by doing this
okay so a5 that's that's a very strange
move
i don't see any reason that we shouldn't
just take the spawn
and yes we have doubled pawns but it's
still an extra pawn so
you know an extra doubled pawn is better
than no extra pun at all
and a7 is protected obviously so he
can't take that pawn either
yeah this is in the category of like
random pawn moves but
in the absence all things held equal
grabbing some space
is not a bad idea provided that you
don't weaken that pawn
yeah we we are in the territory where
giving a check on you one might actually
be a good thing now
all right
rook c5 and that is kind of just
collapse because now
this gives us another pawn on b2 that's
why we put our queen there
and now he's starting to hang to hang a
lot of pawns
and that's just what happens this is how
these games often go
um you put pressure pressure pressure
and then kind of this coll general
collapse tends to happen and it's
totally normal
okay what do we do now
well now is a perfect opportunity
to do what
well we can push the pawn yeah we can go
a4
but i would also even argue that a check
on d1 could simplify the position now
we're in the territory where trading is
great
and we actually have the opportunity to
checkmate him
if you look really carefully that king
on h2
could be checkmated on h1
we can't go rook h1 here we have to
defend that square of the queens we'll
have to double on the first rank
so do we go queen b1 well queen b1 is
sloppy
because queen b1 relinquishes the long
diagonal remember how important it is to
control this diagonal white's got a lot
of checks on that diagonal so we want to
make sure we go queen a1 also we protect
this pawn that's not that important but
it's something
and now we're threatening checkmate
we're up three pawns this is winning
we're just gonna have to be
precise until the end
okay
rook takes h5 does nothing it doesn't
defend against mate but it's a good
thing to notice this is essentially
resignable
this is essentially resignable
yeah queenie five check would trade
queens but then we're just up three
points
so it's stuck between a rock and a hard
place
queen c3 check same thing
okay here we have a very accurate move
you guys should know that rooks belong
behind pass pawns in the end game but it
seems that it's impossible to put the
roof behind the pawn because there's a
lot of traffic but it's not we have this
really elegant move rook t6 get it to a6
and then start pushing tying down
white's rook white has to be stuck in
front of the pawn
which immobilizes and then we bring our
king to that side of the board
this is a really cool like say the rook
is sandwiched between the two pawns
uh you don't even care we could remove
the a7 pawn from the board that would
change nothing the important thing is
this a5 pawn that's the one that's going
to be doing the heavy lifting
yeah thanks nivenyo and yeah if you
enjoy this kind of content um
the the support has been tremendous and
i i really appreciate it all of the subs
and all that stuff really helps and
thanks
to everybody
okay okay six
it's september so give me your damn sub
no just kidding
okay g3 and obviously we just push
and we push all the way to a2
okay
not kidding at all why would i ever be
kidding
okay just watch for moves like rook c6
so never pre-movie like never pre-move
in these positions
brooke thank you for the prime see i i
got to somebody at least
okay so what's the what's the actual
winning strategy here and it's not
embarrassing to be like i don't really
know what we need to do here the
winnings there's many ways that we can
actually
win well you never you don't want to
move the stroke away from a6
you want to get white to trade on a2
because that would get into a pawn end
game we're up a million pods first thing
though is to get the king up without the
king being
in the action you're not gonna get
anything valuable done
and the secondary step is to mobilize
the majority as somebody is saying so
let's give a check on a4 toss the king
back
let's toss the king back
and then let's start
you know getting getting the pieces to
the to the party
so first we can bring our king up to f5
and then we can start pushing the pawns
within with the ultimate aim of creating
a passer on the king side as well
okay so here um
g5
i'm going pretty fast here this is very
intuitive
i don't think this is like any anything
difficult
well i didn't want to go king e5 i'll
show you why i i wanted the king
specifically on f5
there is actually a reason
yeah this is over kings c4
um
okay let's take it and you know one
approach is to go rook a3 and just
pick off all these pawns and we could
even give up a2 if it means taking the
other two pawns
this is just resigns yeah good game good
game
all right um
so
let's quickly go over it okay d4 takes
takes d6
yeah so this is one of the topical
positions of the elephant in fact
the modern move is to play knight f3
here
um yeah you're very welcome and
black can't take on c3 because the
knight hangs so this is considered i
think a little bit more precise although
you could obviously take
okay so e6 is not not the greatest move
but it's fine
this is not the reason that white lost
okay knight f3 knight c6 knight c3
bishop g4
um
one thing that you have to be careful
about
in these types of positions
is the move thank you blundersmore for
the nine months
whenever you move your bishop out of c8
like this it leaves the b7 pawn a little
bit loose so what move do you always
have to check for
when you get that bishop out in this
type of position broadly speaking
especially when there's a piece on d5
that's a little bit loose yeah the move
queen b3 is one of the most commonly
missed types of ideas in the opening
people just forget that this kind of
move exists
i can show you a million examples it's
it's just a common source of a blend
thank you cardona mamarosa for the tier
one
let's go
why is this not dangerous here well
because i can take on f3
the bishop defends the knight so white
has to take and ruin the structure
entirely and here we can just go e6
and this is a classic
sacrifice like queen takes b7 is just
not dangerous we go rook b8
and in return for this pawn
we have completely ruined white
structure
we can even just go bishop b7 here white
is totally undeveloped and this knight
can come to b4 at the right moment it's
just a bad position for white it's not
even full compensation black is just
better
black is just better
um
so that's how we would have dealt with
queen b3 bishop b2
e6
h3 and yeah i would say that we're
slightly better
castles bishop b7
yeah remember that in response to queen
b3 you can actually sacrifice this pawn
you don't always have to automatically
defend it
um
okay so he goes
rookie one castles
and yeah bishop g5 i think is the first
serious mistake
it's not an easy position to play for
white
uh not at all
um
but maybe i don't know bishop e3 for
example is is a move that i would
entertain here for white
just kind of accepting yeah the position
sort of sucks but i'm not going to trade
any pieces unless it involves improving
my pawn structure so this for example is
a pretty favorable trade for white
i just wanted to pull up an example of
what can happen when you miss queen b3
yeah so what can happen when you missed
queen b3
i had this live okay i'm playing at 1200
in this game and this is like california
state championship but in this lobby
goes bishop f5 which is a big mistake
and the reason it's a mistake is
precisely because of queen b3 now this
doesn't look like a dangerous move my
opponent goes b6
but watch how quickly black's position
deteriorates i go bishop f4
e6 and knight b5
after knight a6 the move queen a4 is
simply crushing and this is where he's
paid the price for the move b6 now the
knight hangs
there is a um
there's a discovery here and
bishop before check simply bishop d2
okay
again obviously he blunders a piece in
everything but he's already totally lost
um just a little little way to
illustrate
what i mean when i say that queen b3
could be dangerous
and after bishop g5
bishop g5 takes takes takes
um
oh yeah before i do this i was going to
um
explain why i didn't want to go g6
the reason i didn't want to go g6 has to
do with the bishop being on g4 i've said
this before but i'm going to repeat it
when you fianchetto your bishop it's
often not a great combination of moves
to have one bishop like this and the
other bishop fiance why because white
plays h3
and the problem with the move g6 little
known issue is that you can never really
play bishop h5 because of g4 so here you
have to go back
but this is also a little bit awkward
because even still wiping og4 and the
bishop has to go further down this
diagonal but by taking by playing g6 you
take away that square from a bishop
and so you got to be careful about
combining these moves
okay so hopefully that makes sense
bishop g5 takes takes
takes takes
rook d8
queen three g6 i i still think that the
position is very much holdable this is a
very big mistake
because this simply does black spitting
for him so
how should white go about this position
well i think the only serious move
is actually just rook d2 this is
essentially forced because you have to
stop the fork and defend the d2 pawn and
it's not so easy for black to make
progress here i think we would have
played queen f4
and after knight f3 we probably would
have doubled our rooks black is better
but light is holding i mean white is not
losing the pawn yet
yeah
so this is just not good knight takes d5
knight takes d4
thank you brave ulysses for the six
months let's go
and um
yeah now
now we're just up a pawn and this is
a pretty brutal position to have to
defend
um rook to c7 tactic yes rookie c2 king
g7
the next point
why what was i planning against rook c7
um i was planning the move queen to e5
okay what the heck is that you might be
looking at this movement saying okay i
get that it attacks the rook but you're
just blundering the pun
well no i'm not because that queen's
defending h2 so this is checkmate
um
now you might say okay well i'm going to
be smarter than that i'm going to take
this pawn to the rook and then if we
trade rooks well then black will no
longer have a back crank mate but here
um i was planning to move rook to d3
creating a highly unpleasant situation
for white the queen cannot leave contact
with the d1 square it's going to be made
and if the queen drops back i have rook
d2 and black just gets a huge initiative
here the queen comes into e2
and in return for the pawn black's
position i just verified this with the
engine
white can hold on
with queen a4 but here there is a really
sexy tactic
that involves the undefended rook on c1
i didn't see this during the game
can anybody find it
yeah flame pelt definitely deserves a
sub
rook takes h3
rook takes hp out of nowhere
lose pieces drop off
white structure is ruined and black is
winning
so this kind of stuff happens
so that's what i was planning dropping
the queen back and creating the threat
of backrank mate in order to defend the
pawn indirectly
and um final point that i want to make
in this game h5 to expand
final point that i want to make in this
game
very minor why did i put the king on f5
and not on e5 so one thing you have to
be careful about when you're tying your
rook down
is to not allow this switcheroo white
gets the king to b2 and then white does
the switcher rookie one check
and then the king drops back to a1 and
this is a little bit harder to deal with
because the rook is obviously
a more annoying defensive piece than the
king
so you don't want to allow that to
happen that's why i kept the king
away from any possible checks
okay so that's that's the final subtlety
the rest is easy
all right guys thank you so much and
goodbye for now thanks for hanging out
you